ich ärgere mich zutiefst darüber wie
kinder und jugendliche in der korona
krise immer hintenan stehen klar wir
kennen alle diese politiker setzte
schulen und kitas haben priorität
schulen werden als letztes geschlossen
als erstes wieder geöffnet und dann sind
wir wieder immer wieder an dem punkt an
dem sich alle erwachsenen entspannen und
die lockerungen genießen können und für
kinder gibt es wieder am strengsten zu
dabei haben sie ja die
seltensten schwere verläufe corona ist
für kinder in den seltensten fällen ein
problem und das wird aber überhaupt
nicht berücksichtigt und ja also in nrw
gibt es jetzt eine erschreckende zahl
30.000 schüler sitzen dort in quarantäne
obwohl nur jeder fünfte von denen
positiv auf corona getestet wurde das
ist schon wieder so was wie
schulschließungen und dort hat das
schuljahr ja gerade erst begonnen da
können wir uns ja ausrechnen wie dass er
sich über den winter noch entwickelt und
frei tasten kann man sich dort auch
nicht in hessen gibt es schulen da muss
man die maske sogar auf dem schulhof
tragen grundschüler wurde ein
grundschüler bis zu acht stunden lang es
gibt kaum berufe in denen wir das
erwachsenen zumuten und das macht mich
rasend ich bin wirklich also am rande
der politikverdrossenheit ich kann weiß
überhaupt nicht welche partei ich noch
wählen soll es ist ein in der politik
ein völlig unbesetzte und unbesetzter
fleck ja also niemand hat sich da jetzt
wirklich drauf gestürzt da diese
frustrierten familien abzuholen und ja
ich sehe es erst mal schwarz vom winter
hier ist erstmal schweigen in der runde
ich glaube weil viele von uns ist
ehrlich gesagt nachvollziehen können ich
weiß nicht wie es in der draußen geht ob
sie kinder haben ob sie keine kinder
haben wie sieht es mit der massen
pflicht sehen ich muss sagen lydia ich
würde dir zu 100 prozent zustimmen ich
würde sogar so weit gehen sofort zu
fordern dass die massen bei kindern
abgefallen das mit grundschülern wenn
man das hört man dann wird er ganz
mulmig weil wir werden uns noch ganz gar
nicht absehbar was das mit den kindern
macht wenn die wenn die kommunikation
für soziale intelligenz wenn die alle
gelände jetzt aufwachsen nur noch
menschen masken sehen und ich sehe auch
nicht wirklich das ende es wird uns ja
immer wieder neue karte vorgehalten also
ist aber auch nicht absehbar welche
langzeitfolgen auch corona infektion bei
kindern haben also die sind vermutlich
noch mal andere als die tatsache dass
sie ein jahr lang was wissen wir denn
wir haben damals immer ein gespenst an
die wand gemalt über das ist ja wohl
noch ein viel größeres gespenst naja
aber im römer wussten ja man muss ganz
klar sagen dass wenn kinder anderthalb
jahre lang immer im unterricht maske
tragen das ist er klar ist dass das
pädagogische
schwere folgen hat und es ist längst
klar dass der schuh lockdown für kinder
viel gravierendere folgen hat vielleicht
wirklich ziemlich erschreckend und es
ist ja auch es ist nicht überall so in
bremen zum beispiel mussten
grundschulkinder schon ganz früh wieder
keine masken tragen in sachsen mussten
sie nie masken tragen ja also es gibt
gab auch immer wieder länder die es
anders gemacht haben aber wir haben uns
immer orientiert an den strengsten wir
orientieren uns auch immer am
schlechtesten jetzt gibt es in amerika
kinder viele kinder in den
krankenhäusern
das kann man aber überhaupt nicht auf
dass deutsche oder überhaupt auch auf
europäische das europäische
gesundheitswesen übertragen und wir
orientieren uns nie an so guten
beispielen wie dänemark oder die schweiz
den die schulen fast nie zu hatte wir
nehmen uns immer die schlechten
beispiele um möglichst streng zu
regulieren flüge hier nochmal ganz
kleine eine nachfrage begleitet ist ja
die ganze zeit für unsere bild der in
einem politiker zu arbeiten weil sich
das wie ist es denn der
krankheitsverlauf bei kindern also wenn
meine information die ich heute gesehen
habe stimmt ist es bei vielen a
symptomatisch also sogar ohne symptome
und es gibt sogar professoren die sagen
das risiko der impfung auch bei den ab
12 jährigen ist vermutlich höher ist die
erkrankung selbst wie sieht es damit aus
wie es die erkrankung bei kindern was
gibt's seiner wissenschaft genau es gibt
ja diese herzmuskelentzündung die in
amerika aufgetreten ist bei einem von
16.000 geimpften jungen da ist es noch
mal häufiger die wo ist aber behandelbar
aber klar ist wir impfen und jetzt guck
ich wieder auf das deutsche system in
amerika gibt es andere probleme da gibt
es sehr große lücken und auch in kleinen
zweiklassensystem das ist mit unseren
nicht vergleichbar aber in deutschland
ist klar wir impfen
die schüler um die schulen offen zu
halten aber nicht weil die schüler ein
gesundheitliches problem mit corona
hätten denn es ist einfach sehr sehr
sehr selten
der seiten überhaupt bemerkbar also
viele haben antikörper und wissen ist
gar nicht dass die korona hatten und es
gibt auch neue untersuchungen die
einfach zeigen dass kinder superkräfte
haben weil kinder einfach diese viren
viel weiter oben abwehren und einfach
viel besser damit klarkommen und es gibt
auch untersuchungen die zeigen dass es
für kinder
sehr viel dass der schutz der man hat
wenn man eine corona krankheit
durchmacht langanhaltender ist also die
immunisierung länger anhält als durch
eine impfung
warum dann die masken ich bin absolut
erschreckend erschrecken weil was ich
eine lobby haben also kinder haben alle
einig dass man einfach an und der satz
wenn das so wäre wäre wenn das so ist
müsste seinen riesigen aufschrei geben
wenn das so wenn das wirklich so ist
auch da wieder raus wir dass wir kinder
impfen um schulen offen zu haben aber
nicht ihre gesundheit wegen dass das ist
bemerkte wie pervers das ist das ist
sonst aber ich sage also ich sage ich
lass mir ich lasse mich impfen was ja
immerhin ein ziemlicher invasion in den
körper ist um auf eine party zu gehen
oder um nach mallorca zu fliegen das ist
doch steht das ist doch unverantwortlich
dass ich bin auch geimpft aber ich habe
mich geimpft und meine gesundheit legen
weil ich möchte nicht an einem stück und
sterben aber wenn man bei meinen kindern
bin ich mir da nicht so sicher ob das ob
das an gesagt dass mit ihr im
teenager-alter aber die sagen wir wollen
alle aber die sagen nicht aus sorge um
die sagen wir wollen reisen wir wollen
in die disco gehen und da muss ich sagen
dass ich irgendetwas aus der balance
geraten also wie ich sie ziehe mit
lauter damen ich meine wie viel wurde
geredet über die gefahr der pille und
das war im vergleich dazu
geringen mit irgendwelchen thrombosen
und plötzlich um und plötzlich sind es
ist in dieser wird über diese risiken
überhaupt nicht mehr gesprochen als auch
mal über die risiken der pille wurde
viel geredet also für mein dafürhalten
als konservativer nicht viel genug aber
ich hab' ich habe zumindest mitbekommen
dass darüber geredet wurde das ist noch
nie so gesamtgesellschaftlich über
thrombose et cetera gerät
wie seit dieser krämpfen also die
diskussion die es danach gegeben hat hat
es noch nie in bezug auf die pille
gegeben schade eigentlich oder wer
richard wie wir punkten laute sachen in
unserer ein benehmen übernehmen wir
nehmen den neben dinge und dann noch
weil wir da nicht alexander das volk
ihren das machst wenn du das machst du
deine gesundheit dingen aber wenn du
wenn du dich wirklich
schweres mitteln imst la riana zum
beispiel also gegen die gegen gegen
gucken mich ohne diese malaria zu machen
sehr schweres müssen sich nämlich nehmen
das mittel weil ich in die disco gehen
wenn du sagst es wenn ich fertig malaria
bekämpfen bild das heißt wenn du wenn du
eine wenn du eine impfung machst wie
injizieren lässt macht so dass er um
seine gesundheit zu schützen aber nicht
auf eine schule offen zu halten um auf
partys zu gehen oder auf eine eine reise
anzutreten da die diskussion ist dann
ist er vollkommen aus dem aus dem kiel
geraten finde ich also da muss ich auf
jeden fall recht geben ich glaube dieses
aus der balance geraten
tatsächlich waren alle corona diskussion
im bezug auf kinder meines empfindens
nach nie in der balance also diese ganze
kinder thematik nicht nur schule sondern
auch kita es gibt so viele
wissenschaftler die davor warnen dass
jetzt kinder zum teil ein jahr lang
anderthalb jahre lang nicht in der kita
waren und jetzt eingeschult werden und
die haben all das was sie gerade aus dem
kantig wenn sie aus migrantenfamilien
kommen die in der kita deutsch lernen
und all diese ganzen dinge die das nicht
bekommen haben und jetzt einfach
eingeschult werden ist so schwierig das
alles nachzuholen und diesbezüglich sehe
ich überhaupt gar keine
fortschritte oder überhaupt gar keine
bemühungen da in die grundschulen
irgendwas rhein zu investieren ja und
sagen hallo herr über oder ich glaube
jetzt hier haben wir meine jungs lesen
lernt versagte absolut im bereich
bildung und wurst um die bildung unserer
kinder vor allem geht und dass das
eigentlich beschämend dass hat da kann
ich ihnen nur zustimmen
[Musik]